[Music]
my name is the Takeshi no medical doctor
working on National Cancer Center
hospital is today although I'm mother
happy to be here under giving the chance
to present here so I would like to talk
about the clinical value of the virtual
sequence this is a new concept are
utilizing nationwide Chancellor gamble
database so first of all I would like to
show you the current Chancellor a talent
viejo pillars including the surgery and
chemotherapy and a large Ossipee and
MSRP these are very important to patient
to be cured or the palliative to prolong
over survival so more more focusing on
the advanced this stage fo and the salon
chemotherapy and immunotherapy and the
central central Maine State well it's
advanced disease so currently so many
pharmaceutical company intended to
clinical development using the Kemosabe
and the immunotherapy and so on so this
is a very important curve this is the
survival curve using the copper America
you can see this dope line mainly mainly
survival like each time x-axis showing
the time from the treatment and you can
see the survival goes down and goals are
go down this means a patient pass away
died during that critical cause not
using that any Kemosabe however
patient Allah see this unconventional 30
a state of art best treatment to date so
for the patient of survival go up
comparing into the Delta line doctor I
mean the best supportive care
so however 2015 Obama President stated
the precision medicine initiative
this means the corresponding surfy
regime acciden America this is how the
precision medicine into the patient's
receive it as such a feat prisoner you
can see here that
tsubame rate goes up and goes up goes up
the Sun patient be cured even in the
patient originally diagonals for the
advanced phase this is the epic mating
surah zebra patient receiving such a
precision medicine corresponding to drug
where the gene acts so we created
initiated scram Japan product since 2015
this is a nationwide AG animal chance
again most winning project including the
lung cancer eros is club under g8 sprain
this is a gastrointestinal cancer in
turn the so many pharmaceutical
companies here joining in this project
more than 200 hospital across Japan also
joining in this project the detail
central and administrative office is
common across the else is from Andrea
strain so a participating v from a
pharmaceutical company will spend by the
measurement of the comprehensive and
next two generation sequencing tests by
the central banner this is the overall
picture of our scrum Japan product so to
date this is the achievement for
ourselves you can see here that 30,000
the patient received and next to
generation tester
and you can see here the 300 a patient
hello the cricketer either
investigator-initiated liar as well as a
company sponsor cricket liar
more than 270 hospital across Japan also
be participating ongoing clinical trial
15 ongoing clinical already the 70
pharmaceutical company included in this
project of course a domestic company as
well as an international global company
also to date are achieving here who
approved drugs who approved companion
diagnosis already achieved and you can
see here an auditor clinical
pathological gain on data sharing on
time sharing with academia firma already
achieved so this is a big large-scale
data set already are we created so
however one of the big problem energy as
testing takes too much time you can see
to two whole weeks needed to get release
out at a to patient each patient because
the more than hundred genes or
simultaneous measurement over the more
than hundred genes so we spend too much
time - two whole weeks so a brighter
future considering a brighter future
minutes was second level testing will be
realized it's a very excellent news to
the patient so a proceed this is a flow
over the initiating cancer to ligament
current clinical cancer cause the
patient ability hospital and then the
biopsy actual orbital in cage chance of
a known cancer we dis discriminate
adapted this leader in cancer doctor the
pathological diagnosis this is a loser
why one to two weeks in error
after that yeah you can see additional
slide is needed for energy as testing
spend to two whole weeks
double score you can see here so patient
waiting for a tourist three to six weeks
to start that treatment it's a very long
time for the patient so I would like to
ask you if you your family are diagnosed
with cancer you choose immediate
conventional stated selfie or a three to
six week later a precision medicine
which one do you deal of you here so you
are waiting for three to six weeks a
very long time if you are a counselor
you okay okay but I guess the best
scenario here immediate precision
medicine no those no time no waiting
time it's a very important issue so I
guess the new concept here the batch of
sequencing if we omit him here testing a
weeks two to four weeks or meeting these
two to four weeks this is only in a few
minute or second level we call this as a
virtual sequencer so I guess if the next
year 2020 s we achieved minutes was
second level diagnosis called the battle
circles which we will be dear lives of
patients are happy I said so this is a
very clinical barrier of the bunch of
sequences so methodology here lutein
well you can see the Hema talk to him
origin standing by the pathological
examination in the loo - Mary what
worldwide you can see all the sketch and
then the directory diagnosis genetic
alteration escaping dissection and
Chason so we use the our large-scale
database
we now conducting their learned by the
training later are using the our
large-scale data set and they we also
created a battle sequence algorithm as
an validated by the verification data
and this is stab is very important to
hourly data make a Mission Impossible
Project possible so this is a
preliminary result in of annex where GX
witches are already are used in the
clinical practice but they are it
confidential
we totally destroy the decision however
you can see for in a preliminary results
show luc point nine hole which means
near-perfect to concordance near-perfect
to concordance between the dr sequencing
and the virtual secrecy I guess so
this is a this a you see is a per
patient data so nearly 95 96 percent of
the concordance we achieve it already so
looking at the leo energies sequencing
you can see the cost thousands of
dollars each test however we realizing
the bunch of sequencing I guess
realizing low-cost H test it it's a very
important huge labor effect on saving
cost so this is the final slide overall
scrum Japan Genesis project this is a
first step to usually a digital badge of
seconds we have a low table database
very strong Inca critical info speech
meaningful Kemosabe history and the
genomic level and a CC bond and American
history and solo zone so this database
is the grossing grossing because of the
input from the several hospitals
updated already and also will have a lot
of IT company jennamariea Papa ray and
the crowd ways and the Google have a
chance to user GC people at home so I
just need an extra generation
cutting-edge Pratt one on JCP are
shifting from another crowd which will
be the monumental wing to prove the GCP
value and the credibility with a huge
lipo effect so my presentation of finish
and moving to the second of speaker the
chairman of the crowd proud race you see
the me son please next speaker I'm sorry
I am NOT doing so good that the English
so now I'm speak from Japanese Saku dojo
Sakai document actually crowd is to know
chairman oh yeah pretty much no karada
snake on KY no project oh oh no this
endlessly NSYNC oh that Torito goddess
name a Koga gGPO thioester KD Atari toka
so technical Naboo ananka a roses me a
stay-at-home optimist mother
Tata Arkansas Oklahoma City beside him
oh no oh don't you see a you know
training another way up till Kaiser this
year her husband Corrado excited G only
G no no no oh dear like I said a
gozaimasu cocoon is near DCP Julia all
right
Nico Douga - yeah a savvy CEO Ortega
hospitality loss okay take a this mental
image audio codec raw resource no
consulting Josiah Hudson yahushua
Sherrod I call or training logic emily
alyn hope you take your cereal crisis
my happy on joining like you know saying
namaste machina and honestly guys some
more or cook acne Monte Rio nowadays
the journey is relatively much Danny
Honda motor pool niche right take a demo
or you know me I don't know Scott who
Lisa you story must a specialization
till this new Google grab me Tommy T
Morales read an English Cochrane an
optimist a when you got a husband a sec
ID number in mulatto number suits no all
culture is the second Ambo no or GGP
service provider to namaste and even
degree knock Raja kakuni Kok Kok Nico
tango all citizens to stay Smith dinner
crisis hiko Manas Nia Cara so the genome
a great dexterity McCullough or teacher
to exterior manami's catarrhalis a
notional on in unison a side hi - this
akuto hiccup you need not give me the
more a cool project to go Cockington I
know Juliette's Cara classy san agustin
the muscle naka de snoop dogg natok
Chaka Chaka natto is anonymous month is
there
he's only tight on our schedule adapted
or management Ragini a con man across
the tax cut or muscles macchiato or some
nice next today a placenta or mother
look Victor too keen DiMaggio to say a
husband is killed Wow Monica
so no naka de when it has tomainia it's
not no timing there a Alton you know I
think all the sahaja yoga they sank
against Ghana in a kadai has Marta to
you
projectors so Canada's new tank encoder
oh okay Cindy Jo no conscious on oh oh
I dunno oh sorry through Tammany GPU gah
he's only walked out on our project but
uh to the Anunnaki to the Masai suit
wakaranai toe eunuch adidas naoki's a
mod sky Rios incognito has made us mad
ah
hey yo holy see this icon doesn't know
or data or caldo de oz material must
know they're tying in Takei security god
moto mere Alito gonna predict the Heike
God are you myself
Damiano you know Conan not that I think
nano project to be stuck anymore
coconut a steel toe to toe kuqali nice
tiny autumn optimist hi they just send
timeline on this Killing war
could it project Akiko kokino oh god oh
listen the project to keep coho and you
just know at Imani he cost on the
skillet of all the studies name I know
consolidated skull to the world a coach
owning aparicio Disney so any coming to
collect copies what this yeah so I'm
super he sent it all up to say a good
crowd oohs audience carry on you know
just like juniors no oh Co hon this this
is no there Mohan Tony Desai
coumadin ER de los angeles is coca-cola
hypnosis de mama
another you think of the sanity koto mo
deciding akagi's ganado hondana
massaging digna schedule oh oh con
estado y convenient nowadays named
Antonio Nome is showing possibly now a
project Toto you cut all this name
Kanani nobody's near a home Tony Google
Cloud oh oh no cogito you know mantras
sigh Centeno GCPD guitar so Thomas
Buskett are not o sizing tonneau gGPO
mosquito Guinea is Clara gets peridot
etiology Consuela
hi dr. yoga
[Applause]
because you need a Sudanese Scaglione
indicative
mattiyahu watch Melanie Juvenal security
Yoe caucus tool mahouka no closed due to
gravity or cost of power once - you mean
anymore oh there's a Monday night oh you
know they're a kong-chi AGC psi you
still captain ATO
uni econ Idris mozzarella dicks tiny
autonomous
GPU intensive autonomous get them all oh
cool project almost agnosticism on
talking dachshund no against Yoho oh
yeah bill ragazzo oh that's called yoga
atmosphere a koala OD planning on Scotty
hi zigzoo toe-mah-toe minority-owned
mosque and a a GPU in to'kustar case a
nice Oscar a mad equivalent data system
touch today MA in omnipotent ago Thomas
team in Tokyo decide they decide a
soteriology Bo Scotty in the creek iced
tea extract car mean optimist the Kyrgyz
dismissed I know or my project or pseudo
project machine is killer no a DCP they
used were no project - is there a khaki
no seat to the early I couldn't project
or business come by I know Jim city a
project to submit during our stay so
knock along studs no Oh Jima no oh
projects to no khaki no data to know
when I was in the skillet whoa a GPU
usage do you cut the tree not the day
but audience can I do key words can I do
you cannot see a muscle to Yahoo but he
is called oh you gotta see my GP uses to
cut the only one delete square toe
yah he's only the cone heel to toe
mother
Jimmy oh and it's kinda hot today they
want intermittent scotomas little deeper
you can see listen
yeah my dress was on ER kiddo Kalamata
zero don't knock it
Oh go to hotel help it on the ski little
more magic Punta de Rossi sava touch a
guitar guitar a Sudanese Kyle can't you
take your dick stay a Meccano project
Jimmy dock Indian actor who cannot see
more committee
Amy Naga Junie it's cut up Sudanese
Kedah a Joni Yamato
Nanaki bachata project ah a makan nasi
yeah
hi Matan is there a cost oh-oh-oh-oh
budget took you to grow this killing
them or for the moon is nature MA
saku-dono project team vinsanto :
achieve media token in disc a little
more pudding MTV instance though you
know it's got a couple Samba no Jeannie
oh sorry Polly Klaas avocados so then it
becomes didn't I just kill them all
honey
Cousteau Karunanidhi naka de a print all
kosovo today MA preemptive in yard today
instance all-star to policy side I need
us cos connective singing are you ask a
little more since all action the
planning of Morocco Creek I see they
have similar signal in his name it
chanted to to hold on student okok so
it's used to go to their everything
hasta maana Monday nice commit you know
Gramma's Achtung he means best knuckle
Nikki Leone nothing you know they're my
instance I've actually given Naruto
Massimino Jeanne Gil
McCallum oh no oh he's only co-listing a
sky god ah nothing I cannot do Metallica
security is there a condo project on
Gino I do Joe hotel at Cap tilted over
all day he's only a high-security knows
about yoga re masa a Metallica shot oh
come on you know II don't even know
original skull to LA
Tony Hawk I know security do you go
today a motto meliora Tinto say a
Gallardo
so is Integra R monster Monica it is
there none of the marginal sea story don
t you know it's Connecticut
yadi monster is there a mark sticks
dunno about Miss Kitty though my son
Donny
no that's Nicosia so she can I know
soccer up a cloud SDK of scottadito oh
wow a little bucket to me a push master
Nico color is not the chimú go Tony a
competition to God yeah you don't know
Pathan decody planning Thomas Dominico
Oh a pig notice they will achieve go to
no bucket to New York ate a it's not aa
did image recruiting was study a GB Road
Scott any running a pseudo you know so
this way a big toe
Oh golly master hwadam on is there fun
Tony I know kiddo Mina
anoche magazi sweet Oh Oscar fittings
yeah good tomorrow
are you stay my ID nose hit a decade a
Meccano original pocket to entice taking
insidious Reba
ma more producer Chuck cool chorus I
know [ __ ] project you are a rookie has
Mira
Canton in Exeter koalas new
collaboration to come in Alec who you
see a project Oh sweetie Nakada
muscle securing a total security so no
idea ma Tanishq access denied oh you can
see the SUNY has merit Optima Korea
Johnny you gotta go cannot o phenomena's
mundo minha kazuto-dono speed Ocana
projectors not that is there okay I
think one of the very first initial
nito's disconsolate and scary or project
oh Christ Osaka a junior los animales
NATO's e AG biryani Keynesian its kaneto
Yost a foreign country oh my god given J
no co2 consultants kiddo
so load is there a TiVo GP yoga time
Rini
new hundred Scaglione a nanny hasta la
bas with Tokyo this yeah whatever
is the honeymoon an autonomous load a
Google novice on dr. Luka me a Sangha
degree not gonna tow even your multi
time in Kansas to muster up a crystal
McKim cocky do you know how meticulous
machi de negocio en Agri Arkansas
Missouri Dumas thank you
right what's on the phone that is there
much bureaucracy is there yes time Oh
home to limit our kitchen gosh can I do
mati hoji be not scary or not this yeah
a muscle never eat Tino say coladas tato
tony 16 aku datang cannot oh I'm a freak
Ultimo or so nobody's named Acuna tarjay
San Francisco told him at a nice give
them all a so colonies near a sudden II
he dogged in his name on Chuck then
secured oh that's honey reading human do
you think oh that's it in English skills
no corvallis name I know who did she say
- yeah a new number 100 Beauty know
since a rat is near it's okay Mike Okuda
an allocation that toka a data say veto
you got all these they're so cool Kim
GDS name tomorrow I know mega meat
Amitabha no no Scotty Hilo combine in
Nagahama or manipulated this yeah kono
naka de piedra canto organized dungeon I
cannot Oh unique coolican don't die in a
secured at the top I'll ask you the
moral decency more socially in Russia
vascular more cancer mucho cuidado nos
ariados hi
[Applause]
hi Kyra knows I go oh no sir I do not
email security no more oh maccready's to
study snake on kind of project aki-nee
his name a moto you think you know a guy
did not ginko arguing in karate
IOT device the atari toca concurrently
Thomas commentators name Samantha mana
data oh oh don't know I'll get a penis
yeah Annalise correcto the big toe toe
toe claw Oh giggle closes oh did his
name stick in a derogatory a producer
GCB do the data hello dr. yoga hello
Sookie I bi big to carry genomics a be
another nod Oh Oh Chrissy see the snake
I think escape the castle at Anita to
stay [ __ ] India to pass the aggression II
its colony he take your the killer so it
no big kinetic I see key no Kiba to stay
a gGPO
confusing come on you know obviously you
know me take toe or take synaptic
using an optimist mono Korean oh oh hei
Bai 32-car genomics a bi a nano or
consulate we th e re Sagara ago sesame
seeds act i Tomas sorry your Spanish mas
hi folks and so today you had a chance
to hear from some of our customers and
partners and about a very specific
application very very specifically
specific use case that they are solving
for so you should sue miss Anne's team
is working on developing this tool
virtual genomics that essentially uses
some data from the medical images from
pathology images and shows that it's
equivalent to genetic information so
that would help save time and help
reduce anxiety for cancer patients
during the ignacio's and the resume
isn't presented how their usage of the
like how their cloud journey has
progressed and some of the tools they've
used my goal is to give you a little bit
of an overview of how cloud healthcare
team which is my team is thinking about
the space and how we approach the
product development in this space before
I do that I just want a quick question
how many people here would consider
themselves in the healthcare sector ok
roughly I see 50% of people and how many
physicians are in the room ok sir we
know who to call if we need CPR thank
you this gives me come in a sense like
where to point this so let me start from
this slide so this is a paper published
by Professor Anupam Jana who is a
Harvard faculty he's a medical professor
MD he's also a PhD in economics and the
only reason I bring it up his
credentials here is that let's assume
for a second that he can run a properly
design an experiment so the experiment
he designed or the question that he
asked was what happens when American
Heart Association organizes a conference
in the US there are 30,000 cardiologists
and once a year they go to a conference
usually in San Diego and a week they're
away from their Hospital 70% 7 0 percent
of these cardiologists leave their
hospitals now some what something might
happen you know you look at the data
like what
who thinks here that the patient's got
worse during this time who thinks the
patients got better during the
time so that's actually true that's what
he says in the paper like there is data
that suggests that if you are
hospitalized with acute cardiac
situation condition during the week that
all the cardiologists are in a
conference you have better chances of
survival and the data is there you can
take a look at it he turned to ACC and
AAA he got no comment the way I
interpret this data is that it suggests
that sometimes the decisions that are
made in a healthcare system are not
always in the optimal best interest of
the patient right we see this through
this data so and when you look into how
healthcare data is used and how
healthcare decisions are made you
realize it's it's very complex right and
and I think that the position we're
trying to take is coming from a very
humble place here and trying to ask
ourselves where technology or where data
organization can play a role because
sometimes it cannot an emergency room
you need to make quick decisions there
is no time to look at a computer or
lookup data information you need to make
judgment calls but sometimes you can use
data in a more effective way and that's
kind of our mission so what we want to
do is we help there our customers and
partners organize the world's healthcare
information there is a lot of
information out there we see data that
imaging data genomics data is doubling
now every several months so how do we
help organize it how do we make it
secure and how do make it useful right
so secure and accessible this is kind of
the core infrastructure the core cloud
capabilities and then how do you make it
useful this boils down to analytics and
machine learning so these are like hot
themes at every booth you go you'll hear
about it my goal in this short
presentation to give you a little bit
more specifics what does it mean for us
in the healthcare space so when we think
about what we are building like if you
asked like what is Google cloud
healthcare is doing so we think of our
offering is a data platform that is
meant to enable providers researchers to
ask and answer new questions using the
information that they have and we think
of this platform in three layers there
is the data platform I'll go
to each player specifically but there is
a data layer there is the cloud services
layer and then there is the applications
layer so let's talk about the data layer
first so the data layer and basically
means that you have a lot of information
if you're a healthcare provider or
healthcare payer or a research
organization you have a lot of
information that your machines or your
patients are is generating you need some
sort of way to organize and manage this
information in the cloud so what we have
built and released right now it's in
beta is a set of services that allows
you to manage standard healthcare data
types in a fully managed way so what
that means is that we have a DICOM
endpoint that runs in the cloud we have
a service that can manage hl7 v2 data we
have a services can manage fire data so
these are kind of the fundamental pieces
of any healthcare data or healthcare
data set of data warehouse now I'll give
this example of a super high level
overview of I wouldn't even call it
architecture but maybe a meta
architecture and we show the demo at the
conference call our SNA which is the
radiology conference in Chicago it
happens every year around Thanksgiving
and what we show there is basically an
off-the-shelf medical imaging device
that connects to the cloud our cloud can
speak DICOM natively so that means that
you can just connect our cloud and in
just any medical imaging modality or
medical imaging device so the data
arrives to the cloud and then from there
you can either visualize it using
something like a zero footprint viewer
of your choice or you can run additional
computation analytics applications on it
in this case what we have done we use
the tool called Auto ml Auto machine
learning I'll talk about it in a second
but we train a very simple AI model to
separate between a hypo a quake and a
hyper a quake ultrasound mass now what
that means very simple terms is that we
were able to separate water bubbles from
air bubbles now it's a simple demo so
this was only shown for demonstration of
capabilities of the technology but we
have right now customers and
partners that are using these tools to
develop clinical applications on real
data so that's the piece I want to
communicate here the other piece is the
public data set so this is especially
relevant for researchers if you're
trying to test the hypothesis then you
need to I have access to some data to be
able to test your algorithm to test your
application right now there is a lot of
datasets that are public in the public
domain but to get access to them it's
not straightforward you have to download
them it's like oftentimes it's like
large terabyte scale datasets you have
to make sure that your tools are
compliant and and compatible with these
datasets so we want to simplify the task
so we have taken datasets that are
already public in a medical imaging that
domain in the EHR domain in the genomics
domain and we host them on our platform
so that you can come and test out your
tools on the data that is already public
in a more straightforward way so let's
say you data is in the cloud kind of
mentally your data is in the cloud the
question is like okay now what well and
this is where it depends really what you
want to do the way we see our customers
and partners using the services and
running on top of their data isn't kind
of into one of these two buckets one
bucket that I would roughly call the
analytics and the other one would be the
machine learning side so in the
analytics space this word is probably
the one of the more overused especially
in a conference like this so this really
depends like what is the question you're
trying to answer like for example and if
you have an expensive resource like a
physician or a certain piece of
equipment that is very scarce and that
creates a bottleneck for your system you
might be interested to see how can I
maybe over book that resource you know
how many people here have a in a flight
in an airplane or in an airport and
you've been offered like hey if you have
flexibility we will give you a hotel or
maybe five hundred dollars so that you
can stay and take the next flight so
imagine you could do something similar
with an appointment doctor's appointment
or a MRI specialized MRI appointment so
this could be an example of an analytic
query
so bigquery in this context is one of
our products that enables you to analyze
large scale data petabyte scale data
it's an enterprise data warehouse
implementation so the other piece I
would mention here is the identification
especially if you're trying to do some
sort of research collaboration you have
clinical data that has protected health
information like names and addresses it
has also a lot of times things that are
not necessarily immediately identifiable
but can help you narrow down imagine
you're writing oh a mother of ten
children in a town or the CEO of such a
high of such a company came to visit
today right so this information is not
directly identifying but it can lead to
exposure of thi so we have tools that
enable you to the identified data text
data medical imaging data that are built
in cloud services now this problem
specifically we were we're very
interested to solve this because this is
something that we see every research
team reinventing the wheel and building
their own and there is always questions
I get well can your to detect a pace
Nate pacemakers serial number in a city
image so in this case it probably can
there is always the next questions like
well can it detect the name of a patient
that is written on a grain of rice in
Sanskrit because that's a patient that I
had that came to a CT and the challenge
I want to bring up here is that we have
data that shows that even when people
are doing this task manually they will
still make mistakes so you cannot devise
a perfect tool but so the path we chose
is we implemented our tool and we also
connected existing open source tools so
that we can offer our customers a choice
and you can compare and contrast on your
data because that's the ultimate test
couple of things on the National
language processing so we're working
with customers that are solving
challenges like a trauma patient is
rolling in I have three different
radiology reports because they had been
taken to a head CT and a spinal x-ray
and another lumbar CT and these because
of
different machines different rooms they
were written by three different people
can i devise a summary that will like
very quickly tell me what do I need to
worry about what is the most risky thing
for this patient so this is leveraging
heavily NLP capabilities and anytime you
want to use any type of machine learning
you want to have labeled data so we have
solutions for enabling you to label the
data that you already have to create
labels and to train AI models speaking
of AI models here there is different
categories of applications so some
applications are kind of operational
like help me predict when I'm gonna have
a spike in demand so that I can
anticipate that and I can maybe invite
more nurses like if I have an epidemic
or a flu epidemic or if I have for
example bad weather more people can end
up end up happening in the ER so these
are kind of on the operational side
another operational example of analytics
is I'm putting a patient in the medical
imaging machine I want to make sure that
they're positioned properly so that I
don't need to call them again because
the test was done badly so this is an
example where the AI can help me
identify the positioning there is also
the other side which is clinical
applications these are more and more
complex require of course more
validation to go through FDA we have
customers and partners developing these
as well as I'm using some of our tools
so a couple of tools that I want to
point out here Auto ml is a tool that
allows you to very quickly develop AI
models with relatively limited AI
expertise so if you have a team that has
access to data we can show you how to
use auto ml to train models on your data
and if you have a team that has a little
bit more expertise and you want to find
you in the model then the cloud machine
learning engine might be a better tool
for that so naturally I would not expect
Auto ml to produce clinical prediction
value models but with combination using
auto ml and using cloud machine learning
engine for fine tuning you can get
something that can be useful and finally
on the ml piece I'll mentioned that one
of the challenges that we see in the
space is that
of people building AI applications some
companies literally have like one or two
algorithms and they're trying to kind of
see if there is market for it so the we
chose kind of a meta approach here and
what I mean by that is that we we are
building a tool and that would enable
you to evaluate different types of AI
models so if you have a model that
claims to be able to detect brain bleed
for example and there is another model
that claims to be able to do the same
how do you compare them how do you
measure the performance of them on the
application side I mentioned a couple of
open source tools that we've integrated
and enabled researchers to use so these
are view some open source viewers that
you can run on top if you store your
data in our cloud you can use these
viewers and visualize that presented for
your research purposes these are some of
the identification tools that I
mentioned so milk CTP and daikon cleaner
in the context of medical imaging this
is kind of the the best practice these
tools have been written more than a
decade ago but this is still what you
see encounter in practice when people
are trying to de-identify medical data
so what we have done is like we built
our tool we integrated these tools with
our back-end and we offer to our
customers our partners to select and see
what works for them best this is just a
screenshot from the AI model browser
that I mentioned the idea would be here
that you can select an application and
select a data set and you can evaluate
run this application on top of a data
set and evaluate compare to specific
applications we also want to educate the
community and help people develop their
own AI applications so we have published
several tutorials on how to do that the
example here is like super simple you
will never confuse this with a real
clinical application so we built a
classification model for breast density
so the reason it's relevant clinically
is that brands isn't it can be a
predictor of breast cancer risk so it's
usually scored between one means less
dense and for more dense and we have
created a tutorial that shows how you
can use publicly available data set to
create a binary classification between
two types of them
so this is the resource that this is you
can evaluate the different the
performance of the model and you can
tweak it I'll leave this Oh actually the
link is not here
um and not only you can develop this
application we can also we'll also show
you how to deploy this application and
connect it to the clinical workflow
because if you develop the best
application but the doctor doesn't have
access to it that's a problem so there
is there are tools that we are working
on exactly for this purpose so this was
my final slide I want to invite back dr.
Ishii know to kind of summarize and
thank you for your time today thank you
okay so the thank you very much for the
coming there so the I do we would like
to summarize the this this the
presentation more focusing knowledge
about your sequencing so they currently
the Ali mentioned the so many example of
the a I met device but recurrent device
are designed to support the dr.
judgmental although however more
consolingly a bunch of sequence and you
can see here again three virtual
sequence exceeded leo energies sequence
in the near future
currently we are now the communicate
between the doctors and the AI so the
area in Norridge also be imported
science level especially what the
pathology and a pathologist pathologist
also be input to the curation annotation
so the cooperation between the doctors
and the AI is needed to to get the
surface doctor in the near future I will
sugar sure but I am confident based on
our experience a batch of sickness in
the new future exceed Leo energies
seekers more happy life I guess so
virtual sequence
making a brighter future
a possible I sin sir prompt act right
diagnosis an optimal treatment and
neighbor a global access to quality
cancer diagnostic and the lip we affect
the serving cost and Salaam
so this is the our conclusion in my
slide at the finally I would like to
show you our scram Japan Genesis team
and so many Japanese objects and he's a
doctor cotton here proton here okay if
here and then doctor Yama mr. Yamada
he's a in the general media company and
all Sony a pop are a super key mr.
Suzuki mr. Sawicki here and he the
company papillary dr. Fuji here and he
the external pathology and so many
members here sorry I'm ashamed of myself
okay finally I would like to thank you
for your coming here
[Music]